i have not talked about um white house
press secretary jen saki's press
briefings for a while i've just been so
busy with different elements of the show
i haven't been watching them i haven't
been covering but yes covering them but
yesterday i did get an opportunity to
see kind of what was going on and uh
something the more things change the
more things stay the same both jen saki
and fox news reporter peter ducey have
had coveted they are both back and peter
ducey is once again attempting these
takedowns of gensake and of biden policy
on kovid now there is no shortage of
criticism of the united states uh both
under trump and under biden when it
comes to covet policy missteps made
under both without playing false
equivalency what trump did is
unconscionable in a completely different
way than the way that that joe biden has
not been as good as he could have been
when it comes to coveted policy but
peter ducey tries to in order to score
points against gensake
starts pushing anti-vaxx talking points
like
vaccinated people are getting it too
which of course
is a very dangerous talking point in the
abstract to promote given the level of
anti-vaccine sentiment in the united
states given the incredibly significant
protection that vaccines provide against
hospitalization and death so let's just
jump right in and i think this is an
example of gensake doing a pretty good
job of refuting these toxic talking
points and
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
on triple backs still got coveted your
triple backs still got cobit why is the
president still referring to this as a
pandemic of be unvaccinated and of
course the answer uh we'll we'll see
what gensake says
the answer is
it's disproportionately the unvaccinated
who have to go to the hospital who end
up being intubated and who end up dying
even though now
most of the country
by most i don't mean 80 90 but 60
something percent most of the country is
vaccinated it is still overwhelmingly
the unvaccinated that are getting really
sick that's what it means okay now let's
listen to john saki
well i think peter there's a significant
difference between and you just you just
experienced this and not to expose your
public health experience but i can speak
to mine as well i had been triple vaxxed
i had minor symptoms there is a huge
difference between that and being
unvaccinated you are 17 times more
likely to go to the hospital if you're
not vaccinated 20 times more likely to
die and those are significant serious
statistics so yes the impact uh for
people who are unvaccinated is far more
dire than those who are vaccinated will
the president update his language at
some time to be more reflective of the
fact that people who are triple
vaccinated are catching and spreading
colvin i think people president has said
as have we a number of times that there
will be breakthrough cases there will be
people who get covid uh here uh at
different media organizations at
companies around the world uh around the
country who have been vaccinated but
there is a significant difference
between being hospitalized or dying and
being vaccinated with more mild symptoms
so what you have to understand is that
peter ducey is there to try to goad
um jensaki into sound bites for the
purposes of later airing them on fox
news and showing how great he did the
questions are dumb and they're bad
questions by design
because they're so stupid that the idea
is fire up gen saki so she says
something emotional or looks bad in some
way
he is not actually there to be a
reporter and to bring information to
people his argument essentially is
seat belt laws haven't completely
eliminated traffic deaths and also
sometimes even when you're wearing a
seat belt you can still get hurt in a
car accident that's basically the
argument and if you said that to most
people they would say that's a really
stupid argument against seat belts isn't
it this is the most important of the
three things that he kind of tries to
pull we'll look at a couple others in a
moment
the unvaccinated in the u.s
are more likely to test positive so you
you still do get protection against
omicron from being
triple vaccinated but it is so
contagious and it's different enough
from what the vaccines target that a lot
of vaccinated people still uh
ultimately test positive but they are
significantly less likely to end up in
the hospital and significantly less
likely to die it's sort of like a false
equivalency where he goes listen
unvaccinated people get this and
vaccinated people get this so it's the
same well no you have to actually look
at the numbers and see what it is that
we're talking about here and the issue
is they are coming to their conclusion
first which is we don't like the vaccine
we want to talk about being against it
not ducey personally right his shtick is
i got it but people are asking this
question because he's doing it for the
audience they start with we don't want
the vaccine and then they work backwards
from there then they also talked about
coveted testing i'll just show you a
little bit of that
i was home all last week isolating
welcome back thank you i was isolating
with covid after a positive test like a
lot of people watching
and uh a lot of time in front of the tv
i heard the president say did you watch
fox the whole time or other things i
have exhausted the full catalog of guy
fieri content oh okay
and obviously a lot of [ __ ] but i heard
the president say
google covet test near me so
somebody isolating with covid i did that
and the appointments everywhere were
completely jammed so why is it that you
guys were so unprepared
for the
need for testing after the holidays
well peter i'm happy to see you back and
well um i would second say that there
has been a massive surge in cases as you
know and we're a part of in dc and new
york and there's been an unprecedented
in other parts of the country as well
there's been an unprecedented demand for
tests so what we have done over the
course of the last few weeks even before
okay so you know it's another gotcha you
it and it is absolutely true that
testing is a disaster in the united
states it's been a disaster for a long
time uh and um
it it's the the problem here is the
continued um attempt to
give people who watch fox fodder for
justifying not only not getting
vaccinated not even looking for a test
when they have symptoms
um and then here's the last one this one
is on sonia sotomayor you guys have been
very aggressive countering covet
misinformation so what do you guys think
about cove and misinformation coming
from the supreme court it's kind of
weird that he even talks like this you
know it's like
it
what do you guys think about uh it's
sort of like the way you would talk it's
like the way a third grader would talk
to the teacher when they have a joke you
know and sonia sotomayor's false claim
that over a hundred thousand children
are in serious condition many on
ventilators
well i'm not going to speak to supreme
court arguments or statements made in
those arguments
but i will tell you that what is at
stake here is our effort to protect
health workers and most importantly
protect patients
so
you know again it's not that it's
invalid to touch on these issues but
it's all meaningless gotcha you're not
really informing anyone by asking the
white house press secretary about a
misstatement made by a supreme court
justice it's it's just optics and trying
to goad responses and gensake continuing
to do a pretty good job a pretty good
job of dealing with it